- Now, see, I know you as a
very funny stand up comedian
around LA and actually she's really good
if you haven't seen her as a stand.
So now you're an actress.
- Is this acting, I don't even know.
- This is stunting.
- This make you an
actress or a stunt person?
- It makes me both.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- Did you two know each other beforehand
or how'd his work?
- We did not know each other.
- I was a friend of...
I was a fan of hers on Instagram.
And so I just told Jeff when
we were looking for people,
we should bring in Rachel and
talk because she's very funny.
- [Jay] Okay.
- Well, one day he slid into my DMs.
Do you know what DMs are?
- Yeah, I do.
I'm not that old, but yes, I know it too.
But it does sound like
something invasive (laughs).
- Well, I noticed one day
Knoxville was liking a bunch
of my jokes respectfully,
and I was like, "Why is Johnny
Knoxville way more supportive
than my boyfriend on Instagram?"
(Knoxville laughs)
And then, yeah, he slid into my DMs
and asked if I wanted
to have a conversation.
And it turns out I did.
So we talked and then he
invited me in for a meeting
with the director, Jeff Tremaine,
and the rest is history.
- Now, do you know what the
stunts are gonna be before...
Do they lay it all out
for you or you just...
- [Rachel] No.
- Surprise.
- No, no.
You have no idea.
- So that's not really acting.
(both laughing)
- No, it's more like improvising.
- [Jay] Yeah, just more
like hoping not to get...
- I just hope I don't die.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
How do you know that someone is ready
to be part of the "Jackass" family?
I guess you would call it.
- Well, we knew most of the
people except for like Rachel
and one other guy.
And so we brought them in, talk to them,
see if they fit in personality wise,
and then we brought them
in for a two day test
in December of 2019.
Not only to test them,
but to test us because we are older now
and we didn't want to look sweaty.
- Right.
- But luckily within an hour of shooting,
we're like, "This is good.
We're all jelling."
- I just liked the, "We knew everybody
except for two of them."
(Knoxville laughs)
Did you have any serious injuries?
What was your worst injury?
- I would have to say my worst injury
was probably when I got bit
in the face by a scorpion.
- Bit in the face by a scorpion.
All right, I mean, you seem fine.
I don't see
any scorpion marks.
- I'm fine now.
- Where in the face did you get bit?
- It was on my lip.
It's cheaper than lip injections so...
(Knoxville laughing)
- Yeah, I would say.
- I'm always looking for, you know...
- I understand that.
Now, it's funny 'cause
I know you as a stand up
but you also come from
a very serious family.
Your mom is a judge, I believe, yeah?
- My mom, she was a judge
and my dad is currently the
district attorney of Las Vegas.
- [Jay] Wow.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- So how did you get away with anything?
- I didn't get anything at all actually.
- As a teenager?
- No, nothing.
Like there was one time I
went with a couple of friends
to go see a movie in seventh grade
and I made out with a
boy in the movie theater
and by 5:00 PM that day, my mom knew.
And this was before the internet.
(Knoxville laughs)
- [Jay] Wow, okay.
- Yeah.
- So they have a (indistinct).
- I don't know.
She must have spies out there.
- Okay and I assume you were
the black sheep of the family?
- Definitely.
(Jay speaks indistinctly)
Yeah.
- The troubled one.
- Of course.
- Are you the youngest?
- I'm the oldest.
My sister is also an-
- Oh, you're the oldest?
- Yeah, my sister is an attorney as well.
(Knoxville laughs)
- Oh, wow.
Well, so at least you
got a good representation
if you get in trouble.
- Of course.
- So what did they...
I mean, were you always, "Oh, my God,
what are we gonna do with?"
'Cause with me being dyslexic
I was not a good student
and my brother was Yale Law
and all that kind of stuff,
you know, what are we gonna do with Jay?
That was sort of the topic
when I wasn't around.
Were you that one?
Were you the one, oh, my
God, what went wrong here?
- No, I mean, definitely what went wrong,
but people would ask me all the time
if I was gonna go into law and I tried.
I tried for like one semester,
I was horrible at it.
So I stopped.
- What, were you breaking it?
(both laughing)
- None of it made sense to me.
- Now, anything surprised you
about working with Johnny?
Were you sort of like, "Oh,
this is exactly where I am.
We're on the same head space
or this guy is so much
further gone than I am."
What was the feeling?
- Well, it was funny because
the first day we get to set,
Knoxville looked like the Knoxville
I grew up watching on television.
He had dark hair,
he looked pretty much the same to me.
And then as we started filming more,
one day he shows up
to set looking like silver Foxville here.
- Oh, Rachel.
- And I was like, "I don't
recognize this person."
And I think me and the internet both agree
that he has a strong
resemblance to Jamie Lee Curtis.
- Jamie Lee Curtis?
(Knoxville laughs)
Do we have a photo?
Let's take a look.
- Let's see.
Okay.
- [Rachel] I thought I was
on the set "Apollo Weave".
- Yeah, not bad.
Not bad.
But here's what I don't understand.
In the first half of the movie,
he had black hair and then one
day he showed up with gray-
- After COVID, during the COVID break.
We started filming in 2020 in February,
then we got shut down in March
and we resumed again in September.
So between that time I became...
- Yeah, but most films have what they call
a continuity person and they will say,
"Oh, you have the ring
on the wrong finger."
They'll notice the smallest thing.
I mean, when you came in...
- There was no-
- The black hair
and then the silver.
Then some guy, "Hey, wait a
minute, it doesn't quite match."
- You know, we don't
have a continuity person.
- [Jay] Really?
- Yeah.
- I'm stunned.
- Unbelievably.
- Oh, all right, okay.